lily rose à quatre ans récemment elle a
été diagnostiqué autiste
depuis plusieurs mois ses liens une
éducatrice spécialisée la compagnie rend
le bleu wen championne deux heures par
semaine elle l'a fait travailler à
partir d'exercices personnalisée basée
sur la méthode dite aebea analyse
appliquée du comportement mais tu les as
motivation de l'enfant
donc comme là vous avez pu le voir elle
était motivée par tout ce qui était
vidéo
tous ceux qui étaient petites figurines
donc ça on va l'utiliser comme
renforçateur en effet pour valises et
pour valoriser des nouveaux
comportements des apprentissages ce
qu'on cherche à faire c'est que le
comportement
qu'on observe se reproduise plus
facilement chaque jour un nouvel
exercice de nouveaux objectifs et de
petites victoires contre la maladie
associer les parents sont des guides au
quotidien et les progrès considérables
depuis novembre il y est là elle est
rentrée dans le langage donc elle nous
fait des demandes elle vient nous voir
elle nous montre des choses elle réclame
à manger elle au manifeste aussi quand
elle veut pas des choses ce qui évite
des crises de comportement donc dans les
apprentissages scolaires
elle évolue aussi elle a évolué au
niveau de la propreté
mais cet accompagnement coûte cher 30 à
50 euros de l'heure entièrement financé
par nos enfants d'ailleurs l'association
peut compter sur la générosité de trois
entreprises régionales comme ceux
fabricants de saucisses et charcuterie
reconnaissable par son étiquette bleue
sur chaque produit acheté 20 centimes
sont reversés à l'association l'an passé
l'opération a rapporté 45000 euros
avec cette somme l'association a pu
aider de nombreuses familles en 2017 on
a en a financé 650 heures d'intervention
à domicile
notre association également
mais il était beaucoup pour la formation
donc des parents et les professionnels
ou aux approches comportementales donc
en 2017 on organiser six formations donc
qui ont concerné 70 familles et
professionnels
l'opération pastille bleue se poursuit
jusqu'au 27 avril
un petit geste pour une noble cause et
qui transforme la vie de ses enfants
extraordinaires